There's no flags if they tried.
Mm-hmm.
Sad ship.
Fly colors.
Yeah, there are no markings under sails either, no.
Are they Spanish, you think?
Yeah, they wouldn't dare.
Must be a Portuguese merchant ship.
This is heading south.
Spotted by the police as a snail, but it is armed to port.
Oh, it'd be worth a ho--
We won't pay custom duty on it.
You're right, brother.
We'll unload the whole cargo tonight.
Going to be sailing with us.
Of course you can come.
City, we're looking.
Should warrant you if the fucking is a real mess these days.
We're doing the entire Pacifica, and it's going to be superb.
I've seen the architectural plans done by Bramanti and Buenodorti, oh yes, and Michelangelo.
We're extending the library, the Pope's idea. As you can see, everything will be redone.
Have to keep up with the times. I'll show you the Apostolic Vatican Library.
Just what is this, huh?
Toscanelli has just completed.
Who's he?
An astronomer who lives in Florence now.
According to this, he says it's only 4,000 kilometers from the Canary Islands to Asia.
You would just have to cross the ocean due west.
That's what he says, but I'm not too sure.
No, but he's ever tried it, at least not yet.
That reminds me of another map.
I wonder, would it be all right if I draw it?
No problem.
Madeira, a little known island off in the Atlantic Ocean.
Chipre is brief.
Columbus, we just found this signore.
He was drowned unless we can save him, ma'am.
Christopher!
He'll be all right.
Put him on the bed.
Philippa, make that broth quick.
What's your name?
My name is Christopher Columbus.
You're in my home on Madeira.
A sailor as I am.
Yes, I've sailed a great deal, but you, where are you from?
My name is Alonzo Sanchez. I piloted a ship. I sailed far away.
Far away. I sailed to where no Christian's ever been.
Why don't you rest now? You'll tell me later. Just rest.
No, no, I'll be dead very soon. I want to tell the story.
You're really China? And Japan?
Bring me a sharp quill on the map.
Show you. The storm had seen terrible fierce.
We were blown off course to the west, seven, maybe eight leagues from the Canary.
islands and the Antiaz in Asia, that's where we were.
Yes!
Here, take my purse, go on, take some birds, and gold, gold 800 leagues.
Time, that was over 500 years ago, many sailors were lost at sea.
No one had any idea that America even existed.
This is how we imagined the world to be then, very different from what we know today.
Was everybody dumb?
Didn't even know that America existed.
You're right, they were stupid, I mean, we know our geography a lot better than that.
But back then, no one could simply learn about world geography.
It had to be discovered.
And then, what exactly did Columbus do?
Bold in the knowledge of his secret, he went to ask King I of Portugal to send him on an expedition, but the king refused.
Columbus's brother, Bartholomew, went to see King Henry VII of England with no better success.
Then he went to plead his case before Charles VIII of France and his sister Anne of Bourgeois, but they were occupied with a war.
Columbus then tried his luck with the rulers of Spain, Ferdinand and Isabella.
Now, sir, it's an audacious one.
We shall have it examined by the scholars of the University of Salamanca.
And his grace, Bishop of Avila, will preside over the...
You are to go east by sailing to the west.
But no one has ever proven that the...
It is much too vast for any ship ever to cross it.
And St. Augustine himself denied the very existence of the Antipodes.
Nobody would be able to walk with the feet on top and head at the bottom.
Since the world was created, we have explored all the land that exists and that are known to discoveries.
Come now.
In short, we have decided that your project is not a realistic one.
Catholic kings will be so involved.
Realistic project? Your request is quite unacceptable.
They told me I was mad almost.
Father, I have seen those Indians with my own eyes.
And that's not all. I'll show you. Look at this.
Take a look, Father. I brought this back. Look.
Those Indians are there just waiting for us.
Waiting. Now's the time to save their immortal souls.
Father, we have to.
Yeah, they really is. All of them idiots at court.
I was once the queen's confessor. I am welcome still at the palace.
We shall see what we shall see.
...with these ships, and make them available to Señor Columbus here present,
to be accomplished within a period of ten days.
...supply 'em.
Why do we have to ship some ships?
Unless he wants that one over there.
Yeah, well, I wouldn't ship on his voyage.
It's great about it, Martin.
Here's my project.
Look at this map made by Toscanelli, Señor Pinzon.
Oh, I know this map. I have the same one.
well this one was drawn by behaim martin behaim like this one here oh it is limago mundi picture
of the world by cardinal pierre dayy it confirms the belief that we can sail the oceans they're
invadigable they are that's exactly what aristotle said and we can divide the world into 24 sections
of longitude that's 24 hours each hour covers 15 degrees 57 miles which totals 20 000 miles
circumference even more i've heard you're a very good sailor i'm now in possession of information
it's secret but there's a fortune waiting there we could share it take equally just like two
brothers in that case i agree i'm ready to participate in this adventure all the way
don't worry i'll muster the cruise i know every sailor here i can tell the good ones from the bad
ones seeming those two you suppose i can have them no you can't these two are prisoners of the holy
inquisition they are conversos jews promised to the fire of god response you can take they're all
Cut trumps and thieves. Good for nothing but the cabos. Take him.
Hmm. Well, you lads, what do you say?
The air and the food will be much better aboard ship.
And even more important, remember, when you return, if you return, naturally,
you will be pardoned and you won't have to serve your sentences.
Well, he won't sail with that one.
He wants to sail to a place nobody's ever been at.
Travelers have come back.
And besides, haven't you heard about the traveler Marco Polo?
He, too, said there was gold there.
There's so much, they make whole cities of gold, great domes and solid gold, do you realize?
And you won't be sailing with Columbus, the foreigner.
You'll sail with us, the Pinsons, in our ships, and we will pay you.
The munitions. I was lucky. I was able to buy good weapons.
When you do see them again, they will all be free men.
You can send these men on the most dangerous mission.
It was the price of our liberating them.
Louis, I want to talk to you. Come here.
Come on, Captain Pinsons.
This is Louis Torres. The man's a bandit, but he's often very useful.
He can cook and turn the hourglass and call the time.
Keep a count of distance travel and speaks five languages.
Which languages do you speak, Louis?
Well, Portuguese, Arab, Greek, Hebrew, Aramean. Better to serve, Your Excellency.
We're going to India and to China.
Don't worry, I'll pick up Chinese.
Go. To the glory of God. Cast off.
Boy, grasp it is. Dive in and find out.
It's a condition of being given your freedom.
Yeah, but that's really deep. There could be some kind of sea monster, maybe.
Uh-huh. Take this weight and jump over. It's an order.
Again, I caught them all plotting.
Truth is, they just want to go home. Now they're desperate.
They'd like to throw you overboard and sail home.
They'd say you fell in the sea in accident.
I understand their complaints, Father. I may have pushed them too far. Perhaps I'm too hard.
And there, this Martin Pinzoni takes himself for the master of our expedition now.
Yes, I know. If we're sailing today, it's largely because of him.
I am admiral of this fleet. I will speak to the crews.
You see this seaweed? You know what it means. It means we are nearing our goal.
And soon all of you are going to get rich.
Gold, mountains of gold. And to whet your appetites, to spur your enthusiasm,
to the first man who cites land, I'll give a prize amounted to 10,000 doubloons.
10,000. What do you think of that?
That's good.
Look, providence is with us men. With God's wind we sail.
Be ready to unfurl sail.
For the other ships, I'll go to the ship.
It's just he's a foreigner, he knows nothing.
Night closed up in his cabin, studying a lot of charts and things.
I say, let's get him.
I am still the captain of this ship.
Notary, write down each and every name.
And at the smallest hint of any trouble, they'll be hanged from the higher...
The ship's not making any headway.
We have to wait, but if it goes on too long, we might have a mutiny on our hands.
When we can, we'll visit Columbus on the flagship.
He's not getting any better.
That's right, we're stuck, recall.
It's that Columbus, the man's snow-captain. What good is he?
And what if he just fell overboard one night?
Watch it, guys. The Penta's coming alongside.
Look alive, men. No violence, understand?
Every one of us wants to go home now.
He knows nothing.
Stay calm. I'll have a talk.
Columbus, the men won't take anymore. It's been a whole month at sea.
This land of yours, where is it?
Surely you're not like those men, so I recommend a little calm, Captain.
You continue to deceive us regarding the distance we have traveled.
I am certain we have come more than 700 leagues.
That is more than the 500 you claimed.
This land, where on earth is it?
Just a little more patience, Captain.
The birds that we are seeing, the seaweed that we saw under the ship,
all this is proof that we are very near our objective.
You have deceived us, senor, I know.
You have no idea about a route to the Indies.
It's very clear that you made up the story to dupe their majesties.
And if we ever return, you may be sure that they will find out.
I'm admiral of this fleet, senor Pinzon.
It's your duty to obey orders.
you didn't talk like this before we left i am the captain aboard my own ship you are on my ship
this is insubordination be careful you risk your life captain if we go on this way with
the crews ready to mutiny at any time it is you who's going to die captain on the first sign of
wind i suggest we set our course west west southwest coming from no we continue sailing our course do
west one thing he is stubborn has not look isn't he changing course we guess wake me up in the
the middle of the night. I saw, I saw, I saw, I saw, I saw it, I saw it was land, Captain. Just go here, must be land. Those lights have to be fires. You see land, that's not right, Captain. You were Regus, and your reward is pumice, 10,000 gold to blue. The reward, first sighting land, as you promised. But Captain, who was the first to spot those flickering lights on shore? You're being dishonest. As far as history is concerned, we will be considered the first. Pretty strange. What are the cities of gold and all the loaves of silk?
columbus thinks that we're some place in india but it seems clear we're in the anti-isles
this is bell and ferdinand of all these lads sure that's how bring america but must admit it
does raise some interesting questions but you know history is rewritten with each generation
certain personalities are brought to the fore and others are forgotten columbus was in on the
discovery of america but the story is not quite so simple for many years the pins and family went
went to court to establish that some of the glory
was rightfully theirs.
Today, in a small city of Palos in the south of Spain,
they don't have a statue to Christopher Columbus,
but rather of Martin Alonzo Pinzan.